hello everyone I think I'm coming down
with the flu
my head hurts and I'm shivering a bit
but there is no reason not to show you
another game from the match alpha 0 vs
stockfish as I really can't get enough
of alpha zero and judging by our
comments you'd enjoy another game as
well so here it is this game is
absolutely amazing and once again I must
say what I enjoy about alpha zero that
it doesn't play like an engine and it
really raises a lot of questions you
know what if old masters like out of
Anderson and Paul Morphy actually had it
right all along maybe that is the way to
play chess but ever since as part of
loss that match against deep blue in
1997 people started thinking that the
machines actually play better chess and
now in 2017 you actually have top
grandmasters that are trying to play
like stockfish and then here comes alpha
zero and says no that that is not the
way to play chess you know a lot of
people analyze games by Anderson Murphy
tall Englishman Dino and they say that's
that's a bad idea
I mean okay he won the game but
stockfish refuted this but we must ask
ourselves did stockfish really refute
this what's doctors be able to refute it
if alpha zero played that move that that
is the question here so I don't know if
if alpha zero continues with his chess
we might see a totally different chess
played in 2018 19 and 20 and so on so
this game I chose this one because it's
it's a masterpiece
it's I'm sure you've all heard of our
aron nimzowitsch and aron nimzowitsch
played a very nice game in 1919 23
against friedrich Samish they call this
game the mortal tubes one game and it's
a game that occurs once twice in a
lifetime especially when you play
against the top Grandmaster but here
alpha zero creates an immortal to one
game of its own against the stockfish
and I know again it's not the top
version of stockfish I mean I'm sure
very soon people it's dogfish will
will require will demand a rematch as
you know they they can just let this go
on but until that happens let's let's
see this amazing game so alpha zero has
the white pieces and Knight to f3 was
played Knight to f6 c4 b 6 d 4 and e 6
again we entered the queen's indian
defense and it's very interesting
over and over deepmind the alpha 0 is
playing white and stockfish defense with
the queen's indian defense g3 and Bishop
to a6
Queen to c2 defending the c4 pawn c5 now
d5e capture sandy 5c capture sandy 5 and
Bishop to b7 and I just wanted to say
that yeah well everyone says that our
that Anderson move or that Morphy move
is in good stockfish refused this here
in this game there will actually be a
move that stockfish doesn't like it's
it's pretty much impossible to analyze
this game because what you're gonna use
to analyze it with how do you analyze
alpha zeros moves using stockfish that
won't really work but there is one move
in this game which I'm sure you'll enjoy
Bishop to G to now Knight captures on d5
and here we have castles by alpha zero
Knight to c6 and rook to d1 attacking
the knight on d5 and here stockfish
plays Bishop to e7 it seems like stock
wishes are given up the night but not
really if you capture it then nice to be
for forking the Queen and the rook after
the Queen moves Knight captures rook but
after Queen captures g7 and Bishop to f6
Queen G for alpha zero wouldn't really
have any compensation for the exchange
so after Bishop to e7 alpha zero plays
Queen to f5 a very interesting move it
it does put pressure under d5 Knight but
also it's very interesting it kind of I
don't know it when you start playing
chess you're taught and don't move the
same pissed piece twice in the opening
you know you have a lot of undeveloped
pieces here and it seems alpha zero
continues doing this
it's it's using the same piece over and
over in the opening and somehow achieves
an advantage by doing this so you know
just something to consider Queen to a5
and Knight to f6 now II for we have g6
attacking the Queen Queen to f4 stop
fish castles and E 5 now knife to h5
would attempt on the Queen Queen to g4
and rook to e8 and now Knight to c3
developing and even though alpha 0
played already like 4 moves with the
Queen he's not big it's not behind in
development Queen to be 8 now and Knight
to d5 attacking the bishop on e7 we have
Bishop to a fate and Bishop to f4 now
and this seems like like a very nice
moment for stock fish to eliminate this
dark square Bishop it's a strong piece
but if you play Knight captures Bishop
on f4 you get Knight to f6 check and
this is terrible for black king moves
now you capture the night and after rook
to e7 as the rook was attacked
Queen to h3 going for the h7 pawn after
h5 nine capture Sun b7 would attempt on
the Queen and black is falling apart so
after Bishop to f4 you can't capture the
bishop Queen to c8 now adding protection
to the d7 bond now H 3 and we have
Knight to e7 and Knight 2 e 3 alpha zero
doesn't want to exchange pieces as the
black is cramped in you know you don't
want to exchange pieces when you control
more space Bishop to c6 adding more
protection to the d7 pawn because when
alpha played 93 it opened up at the
attack from the rook to the d7 pawn rook
to d6 now not allowing not allowing
stockfish to push this pawn and even
further cramping his position Knight to
g7 we have rook to f6 now and this is
this is astonishing I mean what a move
you know if you
played this it would be like how is that
rook ever gonna get out of there but
alpha zero isn't worried Queen to be
seven we have Bishop to h6 now Knight to
d5 we would attempt on the rook Knight
captures on d5 Bishop captures on d5 and
rook to d1 96 now alpha zero exchanges
bishops
the Bishop captures on f8 we have
chapters on f8 and Queen to h4 and
already you can see that when black when
alpha zero managed to exchange the dark
square bishop now black has some serious
weaknesses on the dark squares Bishop to
c6 Queen to h6 now and now there are
some there are some ideas of rook
captures night and the night the g5
followed by checkmate and 87 rook a to
e8 and rook to d6 by alpha zero it seems
like there might be something here if
you capture rook captures night but of
course stockfish wouldn't capture with
the rook and it it won't capture with
the deep on the only move that - works
for black is f captures on e6 and after
Knight g5 you simply play rook to e7 and
you're fine here there is no
compensation for the piece for the
exchange so after rook a to e8 Brooke to
d6 was played and now Bishop captures on
f3 eliminating that night so there is no
more worry of Knight to g5 Bishop
captures on f3 and Queen to a6 age for
now
now alpha zero is rushing that pawn up
up the board to break open the Kings
position Queen to a5 we have rook to d1
not allowing Queeny Queeny one check c4
now
rook to d5 will attempt on the Queen
Queen to e1
check King G - and now c3b captures and
c3 Queen captures on c3 and h5 now rook
to e7 Bishop to d1 and this Bishop to d1
is an amazing move alpha zero is
planning to play Bishop to d1 and then
Bishop to b3 to get the bishop to this
diagonal
to if7 and this this is such a beautiful
planet and it's wonderful how it's
wonderful how alpha0 can you know make
mix such a such a positional move Bishop
to d1 and we have Queen to e1 now Bishop
to b3 rook to b8 protecting the d7 pawn
and rook back to f3 Queen to e4 now
Queen to d2 and the Queen to g4 Bishop
back to d1 preparing some nasty
discoveries when the rook moves Queen to
b4 and now h6 you'll see you'll see y h6
night to c7 over the tempo on the rook
rook to d6 now Knight to e6 and Bishop
to b3 and in this position if you
analyze it black is actually threatening
to capture d5 pawn and if you if you if
you allow stockfish to evaluate this
position stockfish is offering rope to
d5 protecting the e5 pawn and stockfish
says that this is a draw but alpha zero
plays a move that stockfish doesn't even
consider alpha zero plays Bishop to b3
allowing stockfish to grab d5 pawn and
stockfish immediately grabs it he says
this is bad for white Queen captures on
e5 but now comes rock to d5 attacking
the Queen and what do you what do you do
here stockfish evaluates this position
again as Ron plays Queen to h8 and what
what are you gonna do here but here is
what alpha zero had in mind and why it
sacrificed a pawn Queen to b4 now
attacking this alone rook on e7 9th to
c5 walking and here it comes
rook captures on c5 b captures on c5 and
now ignoring the pawn but Queen to h4
now attacking the rook and this rook
x-raying the rogue behind it so you do
have to do something about this rook to
b8 and we have now worked to f6 and what
what alpha zero did with this Bishop to
b3 maneuver and upon sacrifice on e5 it
completely locked the black
Queen from the game the Queen can never
enter the game again rook to f8 was
played and you have to protect the f7
pawn because the rook is attacking it
the bishop is attacking it and the Queen
will soon come to attack it so Queen to
f4 by alpha 0 and a5 and now we have g4
by alpha zero and here it is the the
immortal tubes one is created and this
is amazing
you know I mean okay the original
immortal Jews one will always belong to
our own names of each but this is alpha
zero created an immortal songs hwang
against stockfish any move black plays
is bad
the Queen can't move the King can't move
none of the points can move okay this
one can move but it loses the game none
of the rooks can move if either rook
moves you capture the f7 pawn and you
win the game any poor move a5 c5 or d7
that moves the loses that pawn and it
doesn't make sense for example a for you
simply ignore it
Bishop to d5 still making it blacks move
a black will have to put the pawn to c4
you capture d5 you capture and after a
three simply Bishop to b3 again you
achieve nothing you just gave up two
points and still it's black to move and
there is no move to be played here you
could you could maybe play this rook
back and forth back and forth but in the
end it doesn't work
simply Bishop to c4 the Queen will
capture the a3 pawn and then this pawn
will march up the board and win the game
so instead after this g4 move d5 was
played by stockfish Bishop captures on
d5 rook to d7 now Bishop to c4 a for g5
now a3 and Queen to f3 again making it
stockfish move and rook to c7 was played
now Queen captures on a3 because black
still can't untangle and if you play
something like rook back to e7 simply
Queen back to f3 and again the a pawn
will
March up the board and win the game so
after Queen captures on a three
stockfish decided that you know the this
can't go on and the stock which played
Queen captures on f6 given up the Queen
but this is just you know not working
she captures on f6 and now look after c8
we have Queen to b3 rope to f8
Queen to d6 rock back to c8 and now a
four and after a four stockfish resigned
the game you can stop this pawn the
bishop will be supporting it to the
Queen also there are all sorts of
threats even if black would give up the
ropes for the pawn and Bishop I mean
you're getting checkmated here there's
another pawn here that will break open
the Kings position simply too great of a
position for white but this doesn't
matter I mean after after stockfish
gives up the Queen anyone anyone can
defeat it what what matters is this g4
move when alpha zero played g4 it
created this beautiful immortal truth
one position that immediately reminded
me of nimzowitsch versus image versus
nimzowitsch
and you know it created it again
stockfish so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it you know all all
comments on this game and the other
games my office you're more than welcome
and what do you think maybe maybe the
old masters had it right all along
maybe you know a favoring activity over
material is definitely the way to go you
know because it's it's very funny that
all of today's top grandmasters they
imitate stockfish you know to get out at
the opening and then when the position
is drawn they almost always just draw
the games but it seems like that's not
the way to play chess and maybe maybe
alpha zero is the answer to chess to
stop all the drawers so yeah I would
like to thank Jason sit bone and Josh
for Jones for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I will make both of
them alpha zero versus top three games
thank you all for watching and
we'll see you soon